all right since we're on the subject of
school board meetings let's play this
clip for you this is a woman this is
also virginia i believe this is i think
fairfax yeah okay
fcps that's fairfax county public
schools in virginia
so many of these videos are from public
schools in virginia
um it's it's a mess in virginia it's not
it's it's again it's like this in men
all across the country but for whatever
reason
uh virginia is sort of at the tip of the
spear right now
so here's a woman
and we can't
there's a large portion of her
address to the school board that we
can't play because we just have to bleep
the entire thing
so there's no point in playing it
but she is very concerned and angry
about some straight-up pornographic
books
that are available in the library to
students
in fairfax county
and she does talk about that and then
she actually reads some passages from
the book that part we had to cut out but
then it's interesting at the end to hear
the way the school board reacts to her
in response to and what they say listen
to this
the books were available
and we checked them out
both of these books include pedophilia
sex between men and boys
both books describe different acts one
book describes a fourth grade boy
performing oral sex on an adult male
the other book has detailed
illustrations
of a man having sex with a boy
the illustrations include
fellatio
sex toys
masturbation
and violent nudity
pedophilia here this is not an oversight
at fairfax
do not interrupt my time
i would like to remind everybody stand
here until my time is restored and my
time is finished
these books are in stock and available
in the libraries of robinson for high
school
and annandale high school
pornography is offensive to all people
it is offensive to common decency it is
the reason why the emp
and then they cut her off now they're
concerned about the kids man there are
kids here first of all i'm looking at
the footage right now
i don't see any kids in the audience
i don't know i okay let's see there do
you see any kids anyone see any kids
there
i see adults i see no children
oh but now they're worried about kids
the imaginary invisible children with
invisibility cloaks that are sitting
apparently in the in the audience there
at the school board meeting
if there are children there yeah this is
inappropriate but
that's why it shouldn't be in school
and you got to love how one of the um
school board members corrects her and
says well those are high school those
are for high school students yeah so
like 14 year olds
they're still minors they're still
children
you freak you creep
you degenerate filth
it's hard to fully appreciate because we
had to again we had to cut you can go
and look find that clip online if you
want to
we had to cut out the part where she's
actually reading from it but it is
graphic graphic depictions
of not just descriptions i should say
graphic graphic descriptions of not just
sexual activity but specifically sexual
activity between young boys and adult
men
and these are books that they put
in the school for kids to check out
is there an intentional
uh plan
to normalize pedophilia yes is it in the
school system absolutely
it's time to really wrap our minds
around that that's not a this is not
slippery slope we're not talking about
into the distant future what might
happen in some dystopian vision of the
of the future
it's not a conspiracy theory this is
what they're doing right now
in the school system
so much of what they do in schools
i mean
sex ed itself
the sex ed program modern sex ed pro
what they call what they call
comprehensive
sex ed in the schools
that is all a plot a plan
to
sexualize children
that's where it comes from that's what
it derives from
[Music]
that's it's
that that is the origin story of
comprehensive sex ed
you know it's why they they have sex ed
classes teaching elementary schoolers
about masturbation and so on
i opened the show a few weeks ago
talking about the the history of um
of the
well-known renowned pervert alfred
kinsey
and even to this day
decades later
you know much of what they teach in sex
ed is based on the work of kinsey
who
was it was a degenerate creep himself
and a pervert
and believed that that
children small children babies were
sexual creatures
and that's why he had you know studies
where he where he would give stop
watches to pedophiles and have them go
rape babies
and time
time it and then fill out a chart to
tell us how many
alleged orgasms the babies had
um
and that was his that was his great work
that he that he contributed to society
in his book the sexual behavior in the
human mail
still is the kinsey institute
still around today
widely respected as well
all of our modern sex ed traces back to
him
and that's what he wanted to do
that was his belief that children are
are sexual
and that no sexual behavior is immoral
that there is that that's that sexuality
is an amoral
arena
any attempt to impose any kind of
morality on any sexual behavior was
wrong was you know ironically immoral by
his
by his way of thinking
so that's where it comes from going back
decades and so we should not be
surprised
to see this sort of thing
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated